over in Spain check out Amber Heard who
knew she could speak perfect Spanish
accent and all come on
exactly one year ago today Amber's ex
Johnny Depp won his defamation case
against her the actress was beaming
outside her reported New 2 million
dollar Madrid Villa pledging she has no
plans to return to Hollywood
as for actress Leah Remini she's firing
off after Danny Masterson's rape
conviction the wheels of Justice move
very slowly the former Scientologist
posted I am relieved that Danny is
facing some justice late yesterday the
That 70s Show star was found guilty of
raping two ex-scientologists at his
retrial Leah hosted a docu-series
attempting to expose the controversial
Church's secrets and added quote this
case is just the beginning of our plan
to hold them accountable I said
was I unconscious
and he said yeah Masterson who's denied
using the church to hinder the
investigation is now in jail facing 30
Years to Life sentencing is set for
August 4th wife Bijou Phillips was
snapped leaving court yesterday in tears
meanwhile over in Amsterdam Bruce
Springsteen had some drama taking a big
tumble on tour
you can hear the gasps in this now viral
Tick Tock as the 73 year old Legend
tripped and rolled on stage while
clutching his guitar two crew members
had to help the boss up as he assured
concerned fans
[Applause]
Springsteen and the E Street Band are in
the middle of their 2023 World Tour
which returns to the U.S in August and
talk about a recovery check out Jeremy
renner's six months after breaking 30
plus bones in his snow plow accident
ET has the exclusive photo snapped
yesterday in La the actor using a cane
crossing the street and holding hands
with longtime friend actress Rachel Lee
Cook nothing romantic they've attended
events together before she recently
supported Jeremy at his Renovations
Premiere a lot of my recovery was
was based on on this show and here I am
I'm standing and making it happen so
here we go an eyewitness tells E.T
Jeremy was walking well with the aid of
Rachel the two seemed happy enjoying the
day last month Rachel commented on his
workout post making a case for miracles
over here
[Music]